on the point of weirdo
uh what that's kind of a beautiful
little statement
what uh what is that i mean that that
seems to be
you know you could think of a guy like
elon musk and say that he's a weirdo is
that the sense in which you're using the
weirdo like outside of the norm
like breaking conventions absolutely
yeah and here that
is either acceptable or even admired
or to be a loner and since so many
people are outsiders
and that we're all immigrants is
selecting for people who left something
behind were willing to leave behind
their families
we're willing to undergo a certain
brutality of switch
in their lives makes us a nation of
weirdos
and weirdos are creative yeah and
denmark
is not a nation of weirdos it's a
wonderful place you know great for them
ideally you want part of the world to be
fully weirdos and innovating
and the other part of the world to be a
little kind of
chicken risk-averse and enjoy the
benefits of the innovation
and to give people these smooth lives
and six weeks off
and free ride and everyone's like oh
american way versus european way but
basically they're compliments
yeah that's fascinating i i used to have
this conversation with my uh like
parents when i was growing up and just
others from the immigrant
uh kind of flow and they used this term
especially in russian is uh
you know to criticize something i was
doing that would
suggest you know normal people don't do
this
and i used to be really offended by that
uh
but you know as i got older uh
i realized that that's a kind of
compliment
because in in the same kind of uh
i would say way that you're you're
saying that is the american ideal
because if you want to do anything
special or interesting you don't want to
be doing
in one particular avenue what normal
people
do because because that won't be
interesting
so the russians i think fit in very well
here because the ones who come are
weirdos
and there's a very different russian
weirdo tradition like alyosha
right in brothers or perilman the
mathematician they're weirdos
and they have their own different kind
of status in soviet union russia
wherever
and when russians come to america they
stay pretty russian but it seems to me a
week later they've
somehow adjusted yeah and the ways in
which they might want to be like
grumpier
than americans not smile think the
people who smile are idiots
yeah like they can do that no one takes
that away from them
you